[Music]
when i think many people including
myself sometimes hear mission we're like
oh boy here we go this is going to be
like
some type of thing on a wall in office
space or some type of kind of lead with
integrity type thing from a ge type of
company where you're like all right well
what does that mean and does that really
have an impact on people on a day-to-day
basis what do you mean when you talk
about
mission
yeah so i feel similarly to you i'm
distrustful when people say that
it is interesting that at duolingo i
think it really has to do with this
first group of employees that we talked
about before that were like pretty big
zealots on our mission
that we really
most every decision that we make at
duolingo is is very mission oriented and
our mission you know there's a statement
of the mission that sounds that sounds
good but and it's i'll say the statement
but i'll kind of explain it more so this
statement is to develop the best
education in the world and make it
universally available the real driving
forces we want to make sure that anybody
who wants to learn can do so
now we're not out there giving people
phones or anything like that we we do
assume that you have
some sort of smart device and the reason
for that assumption is that's just the
world's going that way uh these days you
can get an android device for 30 bucks
so it is kind of going that way
we make sure that our app works on very
low end android devices for example but
we just we really want to make sure that
anybody who wants to learn a language
well not languages but we're expanding
to teaching other things too but anybody
who wants to learn a language can do so
without having to pay us
and this matters to us
and
most of the decisions we make are
related to this but one of the things
that i think has really
affected my thinking and certainly
the company behavior
is we are all really big believers that
yeah the mission we like the mission and
it's great we're all really big
believers that that mission is actually
well aligned with the long-term success
of our company
as as a business entity so as a actual
actual money-making publicly traded
company it is aligned with a long-term
success and let me kind of explain
you know for example
we could say tomorrow you know what
screw it
you have to pay to use duolingo
my guess is we would not no my guess i'm
pretty sure we would make a lot more
money if we did them
our number of users would go down
but
a good number of them would also pay us
and we would make a lot more money and
next quarter would be an amazing quarter
for us like we would i i
it would be an amazing quarter for us i
don't know the off the top of my head
but our revenue probably would 10x some
crazy number in like one quarter would
just go nuts
however
what that would do is it would
completely stifle our growth
because the way duolingo has grown is
through word of mouth
we have all these people who use us for
free they don't pay us we make some
money off them from the ads but you know
most of our money comes from our
subscription
but what's really useful about all these
people that use us is the useless they
have a good experience and they tell
their friends
and the vast majority of our users
i mean really the overwhelming majority
of our users when you ask them how you
know how'd you find out about duolingo
it's like ah a friend told me or like my
my significant other told me or whatever
it's basically word of mouth
and and i really do believe that having
a really great free user experience it's
what's best for the business in the long
run
again not next quarter but if you take
the long view which we are dueling i
mean we've been at this for 10 years i'm
i'm i'm gonna stick around duolingo
probably forever i mean i really love
working here et cetera
so my view now is a long-term view i
mean i'm here thinking about the next 10
years the next 20 years etc and i really
think that
if we do the right thing for our users
in terms of like actually being able to
learn a language really well
and without having to pay us
that is actually what's going to
optimize our revenue in the long term
so i believe that i think most everybody
in the company believes that and i think
that
that alignment has made it so that a lot
of decisions are a lot easier because we
do hire a bunch of people who are like
uh what the hell you talking about
mission like you know this is people who
went to like whatever business school
and everything's like well i'm just here
to make money
so we do hire some such people but i
think once they understand that we
really it's not like we don't want to
make money it's not like we you know we
really are big believers that there's
real long-term alignment here
i think that really
that aligns everybody
you